hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website column today game 12 of 12
in the 2016 World Chess Championship our
competitors today magnus carlsen the
white pieces this reigning champion
black being played by sergei karyakin
and magnus carlsen knowing that they're
kind of tied up he can kind of go
forward all he has lost a game with the
white pieces in this tournament so far
but it's very rare for him for the most
times if he's playing the white pieces
it's a draw or a victory so he's kind of
been peaking at the right time in this
tournament at towards the end he's been
playing better than he did at the
beginning of the tournament my opinion
so all know well go and get started with
game number 12 mr. Karlson starts out
with pawn to e4 pawn to e5 Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop here to b5 so the right
Lopez we've seen this 80% of the time
from this tournament so far and we see a
similar response Knight to f6 the Berlin
defense something we've already seen so
far in this tournament castle on the
King side Knight takes on e4 rook over
here to e1 so exact same moves that we
saw in game number 3 and they continue
with the same moves they played in game
number 3
Knight back here to a d6 Knight captures
Bishop e2 7 Bishop back here to F 1
Magnus Carlsen
he could have deviated any time Bishop
back to a4 could have played Bishop to
d3 lots of different options decided hey
let's go and just bring the bishop back
here to F 1 after the knight takes and
rook up here to e5 castle on the
kingside pawn to d4 and then Bishop to
f6 so the first team moves they did
decide to go ahead and keep doing the
same thing as before now in game 3
Magnus Carlsen actually played rook to
e2 which was kind of an odd move through
the gate karyakin took about 25 moves 25
minutes to respond to this move and
Magnus Carlsen essentially said I didn't
think this was that bad and so I thought
I would just try to throw off his
opponent which he did in game 3 if you
remember that it went well into move get
70 and that was actual game that Magnus
Carlsen made a huge mistake could have
actually won that game ended up a
drawing as he was not able to convert a
passed pawn that he probably should have
pretty distraught after that game but
this one decided okay
can't pull a fast one over on my
opponent so decides to go instead play
rook back here to eat one kind of the
normal move that you see in this opening
recover te8 cardiac and playing strong
defense but says hey let's let's
exchange material if you want I know
that you have kind of the advantage with
the white pieces in the last game so I'm
going to do everything I can to draw
this game or see if you can make a
mistake like you did earlier in the
tournament Bishop to f4 from Magnus
Carlsen just developing that dark square
Bishop rook takes Queen takes and then
out Knight back here to e8 me he kind of
had the decision here this Knight is
being attacked on d6 he's going to be
recapturing with this pawn more than
likely so he could either take here on
d4 trying to hold on to this material
and just give up double pawns on the
deef also after the pot or the bishop
takes pawn recaptures not up here to see
three more than likely not going to take
with his bishop here I'll say [ __ ]
you're back here to e5 or work here to
d1 attacking the pawn may be pawn up
here to f4 can't really take it because
then Queen up here to e4 attacking both
the bishop and the rook so if the bishop
comes back then this pawn is going to
fall although it's going to be difficult
to hold on to that material on board
this I just go and play Knight back here
to e8
not very aggressive but also just
playing somewhat defensive in this
position pawn here to c3 pawn to d5 so
just pushing his material up and getting
it opportunity for the light rare bishop
to get involved into the game Bishop to
d3 a pawn to g6 not over here to a 3 and
then pawn to c6 and this was where I
kind of saw the writing on the wall of
completely symmetrical both sides I
didn't really feel like karyakin was
going to be doing anything too crazy
because he could have from here plate
you know pawn to a5 he could have not
worried about this plate Knight to g7
and then tried to break things up on the
Queen side the board with his pawns but
karyakin like he's done so far in the
tournament said yeah I'm I'm fine with a
drawl I'll play as defensive as I need
to nothing's going to get past me on
this game and madness Karl
didn't seem to be okay with that as well
night over here to c29 to g7 Queen here
to d2 and then after Bishop to f5 there
was just a fury of exchanges on board
the Bishop takes Knight takes Knight
over here to e3 and they just started
exchanging material off the board and
Kuryakin said about Queen to e7 a do you
want to go and exchange Queens off the
board and Magnus Carlsen said yes I do
[ __ ] you're back here takes on e7 work
over here to e1 after the bishop comes
back a king here to f1 they push their
pawns up a little bit but then after
rook here to e8 the row comes up in
exchange and then both sides pretty much
said okay we have a bishop on board a
same color it's not an open board state
so the Bishop's going to be are going to
be doing too much we've only exchanged
one pawn off the war but there's no
material to even do too much so this was
after move 26 they do have to get to
move 34 to be a draw so they play the
rest of moves out in about a minute and
a half and then after that they decided
to after move 30 the bare minimum to go
ahead and announce a draw very
disappointing in my opinion the game
lasted about 35 minutes I actually got
to to the coverage about 28 minutes in
and then it was just rapid fire that
they were already playing rapid in blitz
tile chess
it didn't seem like either player wanted
to really be playing this particular
game Magnus Carlsen afterwards kind of
alluded that he apologized people that
said hey sorry you were hoping for
fireworks that was not my game plan
coming in cardiac and even kind of
jabbed at him a little bit which I
thought was interesting said you know
Magnus Carlsen he just wanted to trade
off pieces he didn't try to put me any
difficult spots which I thought was
weird since he had the white pieces but
hey if that's what he wanted to do
that's fine now Magnus Carlsen for his
credit he is the rapid chess champion
the last two years in a row and if
you're not kind of familiar with the
tiber because we will be taking a day
off and then coming back for a rapid and
blitz style tiebreaker so the first one
is rapid chess they'll be playing a
four-game series they both have 25
it's an in with each move they do get 10
seconds so different than the hundred
minutes they get now with a 30-second
much faster if for some reason it's
still tied after that they will play
blitz chess it will be a five-game
series and they'll have five minutes
with three seconds so very very quick
and then if no one's one after that then
they will play Armageddon which is a
horrible way to decide a victor but and
that whites actually given five minutes
blacks given four minutes and if it's a
tie then black wins because he had less
time that would be the weirdest way to
have a champion but it possibly could
happen now as we said Magnus Carlsen
feels really good about his chances with
a rapid chess so I'll hope it I hope it
works out if it doesn't I do think he's
going to look back on this game 12 and
say I pretty much didn't even try to win
this one so for everyone out there kind
of hoping for exciting game 12 you were
surely disappointed if there's players
out there that we're kind of excited for
more chess you are ecstatic because we
get at least four more games
assuming Madison doesn't win I'll take
three of those right away and then we
don't play that fourth one but all in
all we are going to get some extra chess
so I thank you guys for watching short
video you probably could even tell from
the length of this video that it was
going to be a fast one the other games
may be as fast as well hopefully we'll
have some crazy exchange with a fast
checkmate that always be exciting but
thanks for watching I'll see you in the
rapid chess in two days bye